many of this year's presidential
candidates have written books to
introduce themselves to voters and to
promote their views on issues here's a
look at some of the candidates books in
his newest book reply all Jeb Bush
catalogues his email correspondence
during his time as the Florida Governor
presidential candidate and former
neurosurgeon ben Carson argues that a
better understanding of the Constitution
is necessary to solve America's most
pressing issues in his latest book a
more perfect union and former Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton looks back on
her time serving in the Obama
administration in hard choices in a time
for truth Texas senator Ted Cruz
recounts his journey from a Cuban
immigrant son to the US Senate
Carly Fiorina former CEO of
hewlett-packard is another declared
candidate for president in rising to the
challenge
she shares lessons she's learned from
her difficulties and triumphs former
Arkansas governor Mike Huckabee gives
his take on politics and culture in God
Guns grits and gravy Ohio Governor John
Kasich calls for return to what he sees
as traditional American values in stand
for something and Kentucky Senator Rand
Paul calls for smaller government and
more bipartisanship in his latest book
taking a stand more presidential
hopefuls with books include Florida
Republican Senator Marco Rubio in
American Dreams he outlines his plans to
advance economic opportunity independent
Vermont senator Bernie Sanders is
another candidate for the Democratic
nomination for president his 1997
autobiography now titled outsider in the
White House was updated to include his
time in the Senate and the launch of his
presidential campaign and in blue-collar
conservatives presidential candidate
Rick Santorum argues the Republican
Party must focus on the working class in
order to retake the White House
Donald Trump has written several
bestsellers in his newest book [ __ ]
America he outlines his political
platform and finally Governor Christie
and former governors Martin O'Malley and
Jim Gilmore have announced their
candidacies but haven't released books
book TV continues now Pramila not a
sentry calls how african-american
domestic workers sought to form labor
organizations during the middle of the
20th century
hello hi thank you all for coming to
book culture okay
we're so excited to be hosting the
launch of household workers unite the
untold story of the african-american
woman who built a movement this book out
by beacon press certain but Pamela
Madison
yeah and today she'll be joined by Alice
Kessler Harris
Pramila is a visiting associate
professor of history and is affiliated
with the women's gender and sexuality
studies program at Barnard College her
research and teaching interests include
women in gender race public policy labor
poverty and social movements have been
prior to joining the faculty partnered
she taught at Queens College CUNY and
she's a longtime scholar activist and
works closely with community
organizations and has written policy
briefs served as an expert academic
witness and speaks widely on issues of
labor and poverty and she's written form
is magazine the progressive media
project as well as other media outlets
Alice Kessler Harris is the R Gordon
Hoxie professor of American history
she's also professor in the Institute
for Research on women and gender dr.
Kessler Harris specializes in the
history of American labor and the
comparative interdisciplinary
exploration of women and gender she
received her BA from Goucher College and
her PhD from Rutgers joining us later in
the program is Namrata a representative
from the National Domestic Workers
Alliance is the lead nation's leading
voice for dignity and fairness for the
millions of domestic workers in United
States most of whom are women founded in
2007 and DWA works for the respect
recognition and inclusion in labor
protections for domestic workers the
National Alliance is powered by 48
affiliate organizations and the first
local chapter in Atlanta of over 20,000
housekeepers and caregivers in so thank
you so much and imma turn over to our
speakers thank you I want to start by
saying what an enormous pleasure it is
to be here and to be celebrating this
book with Pramila
it's a book that crosses so many of the
fields that I've written about and I'm
interested in that I'm completely amazed
to see how it moves not just one field
forward but several fields forward the
field of labor history which is where I
started out the field of women's history
the study of working women it moves all
of those into what you might call a
cutting edge place so Pramila I want to
start out by asking you how did you come
to write a book on domestic workers
after all we all know that domestic
workers are at the edge of our
intellectual consciousness not at the
center of it and yet you've managed I
don't need to put them at the center of
it but to think about how that Center
affects all of American history this
book I guess is very deeply personal to
me on some levels but also grew out of
my scholarly research my grandmother
worked as a domestic worker in South
Africa for most of her life and my
mother worked as a domestic worker for a
short period in South Africa as well and
my mother had a number of working-class
jobs and she really instilled in me a
value of work whatever kind of work
people did to value that work and I
think I took that lesson away with me
but in addition to that about 10 years
ago or so I started to read about and
observe domestic worker organizing here
in New York City by an organization
call domestic workers United which was
an amazing group of mostly immigrant
women from all around the world who
began to raise awareness about the
plight of domestic workers about the
abuse and the exploitation and I was
enormous ly inspired by their ability to
speak out and to challenge this
occupation that plays such a central
role in their lives and then of course
there's the question of the academic
imperative I there has not been that
much research in writing on domestic
work we have a lot of research and
writing about women's labor history and
of course your foundational to defining
that field of women's labor history and
there have been some important
monographs about domestic work and
domestic worker organizing but if you
look at the importance of this
occupation in women's history for both
workers and employers we just don't have
enough information especially told from
the perspective of workers so that was
my interest in writing the book
mentioned that there is not a lot of
work done on domestic workers and I
agree but partly that's because we've
always said there really weren't written
sources they weren't good sources so we
couldn't write about domestic workers
how did you get through that barrier the
archive is a huge problem when you are
writing about poor and working-class
women who tend not to leave the same
kinds of documents as other people who
tend not to do as much public writing as
other activists do so I began to think
about the ways in which these women
built their movement and crafted their
movement and the kinds of stories that
they told in particular about their
organizing and those stories really
became the center of my book because it
was in their words their understanding
of this occupation of the history of
this occupation it was their way of
bringing other women into the movement
and their way of thinking about how to
reform the occupation it tell us more
about that what do you mean by
storytelling what kinds of stories did
they tell and who told them well they
well they told stories about their labor
and they told stories about the ways
they were higher
about the kinds of treatment that they
got from their employers and they told
stories about history one women one one
woman who I write about his name
Geraldine Miller who lived in the Bronx
she was an organizer and a domestic
worker here in New York City she lived
in the Bronx
and she told stories about something
called a Bronx slave market and these
were street corners during the Great
Depression where african-american women
stood while they were waiting to be
hired as day workers and Miller told a
story about women who were waiting on
the street corners and employers would
come up and look for the women with the
most scarred knees and she told a story
because women would look for the most
scarred knees because those were the
women who scrubbed floors down on their
hands and knees and Miller told a story
as a way to I think highlight the
exploitation and the occupation but it
also became a platform for reform so as
she told his story she told the the
women we are never ever again going to
scrub floors down on all fours it's a
fascinating story because of course we
associate what sounds like a shape-up
you know we call it a slave market when
it has to do with women but the shape-up
was a common way of hiring unskilled men
to do manual labor
and now you've uncovered a moment where
women go through exactly the same ordeal
so what looked like a gender difference
for a lot of years turns out not to be
one absolutely and the term slave market
was actually given to those street
corners by Ella Baker and Marvell cook
who were two african-american women
organizers here in New York City in the
1930s who wrote an expose about the
treatment of domestic workers during the
Depression and it's interesting because
that names stuck and it's stuck for
women organizers in the 1960s who
probably had never read anything about
the slave markets of the 30s but it
certainly heard those stories and those
stories
became part of their organizing toolbox
so how does it happen and this is one of
the things that really it puzzles me
still even after reading your book you
know I've written a lot about organizing
working women and you know where I come
from the capacity to organize often in
here is in the skill of the worker in
the community that the worker creates
but we always imagine domestic work as
an isolated kind of job so how do you
organize domestic workers could you talk
a little bit about how the domestic
workers overcame that what looks like
relative isolation it's a very hard
occupation to organize and as you know
most labor leaders it during most of the
20th century had deemed domestic work on
organiza Boleyn the women who I write
about actually use public spaces as
sites of organizing so and it's true of
domestic worker organizing today so the
public parks the public buses become
sites of organizing the laundry rooms in
in apartment buildings there was one
woman in Atlanta Dorothea Bolden who
rode every bus in the city of Atlanta
handing out leaflets and talking to
women as she rode those buses and
encouraged them to come out to a meeting
so it's an interesting way to think
about how labor organizing is
transformed when you're looking at an
occupation like domestic work it moves
away from the workplace and into the
public sphere it is completely amazing
especially when you consider that most
domestic workers were excluded from that
vast panoply of legislation that began
in the 1930s so even earlier they
weren't protected by protective labor
legislation they weren't included in the
Social Security Act of 1935 they were
excluded from the Fair Labor Standards
Act
how did it happen that they actually
managed to get themselves covered by
these various acts yeah the the
exclusion is interesting because I think
it it sort of reveals the ways in which
domestic work was considered different
from other kinds of work partly because
it was work that took place in the
privacy of the home partly because the
workforce was largely african-american
and so it becomes a different kind of
labor a kind of labor that's not
recognized and that's not valued the
same way that other kinds of work is
valued and women organize they organize
to fight for those rights and those
protections the the women in this book
lobbied for and eventually won in 1974
minimum wage protections for domestic
workers for the first time nearly 50
years after the the New Deal legislation
was passed and that was an enormous
victory they testified before Congress
and story telling actually became a part
of that of their of their efforts as
well so going before Congress and
talking to feminist leaders at the time
about the kinds of work that they did
became a part of how they made that
claim for minimum wage so wasn't there a
conflict between the feminist leaders
who presumably were hiring domestic
servants and the domestic servants who
were trying to get rights which would be
paid for by the feminist leaders there
was definitely a conflict because these
feminist leaders were mostly
middle-class and were women who relied
on and employed domestic workers and in
some ways it was in their interest to
pay less and to extract more work out of
their employees and so there was a
conflict there but there was also an
important sector of the feminist
movement that was very supportive of
domestic worker organizing and I think
you Alice were actually a part of that
feminist movement because I believe you
were at Sarah Lawrence College in the
1970s
and Sarah Lawrence had a very important
contingent of feminist activists who
actually worked to build bridges with
domestic worker organizers and Carolyn
Reid who's one of the women I profile in
the book went to several meetings and
Institute's at Sarah Lawrence and so I
think it's important to think about the
feminist community is not a single
community but there were very important
people in the feminist community who
were supportive of and I think worked on
behalf of domestic workers as well
Carolyn Reid who you're right I remember
quite well was a formidable and very
powerful presence were there other women
domestic workers who came out of
domestic works work work who came out of
domestic work who were equally
formidable absolutely there was a woman
named Josephine Hewlett who was from
Youngstown Ohio who served as the field
director for the household technicians
of America she was a single mother and
she raised her child and she served as a
full-time organizer for this movement
and she was the one who actually
pioneered a strategy of storytelling so
she went around the country and talked
to other domestic workers about her
struggles of trouble being a single
mother trying to raise her child trying
to live off the wages of domestic labor
geraldine miller was another woman who I
think was enormous ly powerful and
confident and and brilliant and I have
to say you know as we think about sort
of intellectualism and the theorists in
labor history I see these women as
putting forth really complicated
powerful theories about gender
inequality about racial inequality and
about social transformation tell us
about your own research with these women
did they tell you stories did they
repeat the stories that they told each
other or did you learn about them as we
do when we do oral history second hand
it was mostly secondhand most of these
women had passed away by the time I
started writing this book so I did not
have a chance to meet any of them I did
have a chance to have a number of phone
conversations with Mary McClendon who
was a domestic worker organizer in
Detroit although she had just had a
stroke and did not want to be
interviewed in person and she sadly
passed away just as the book was being
published but I was fortunate that there
were a number of librarians and oral
historians around the country who had
the foresight to interview these women
so I had access to a number of
interviews give us a sense of what the
timeline is here when did the big
domestic workers organizing push take
place and can you give us some sense of
what proportion of domestic workers are
now organized in the Union I actually
began my story with the Montgomery bus
boycott and I think that was an enormous
ly important moment for domestic workers
because the vast majority of women who
supported and participated in that
boycott were domestic workers and had it
not been for them the boycott would not
have been successful so I look at their
support for the boycott but I also look
at their leadership in the boycott so
there was a woman named Georgia Gilmore
who was a domestic worker who went to
the first mass meeting that was called
in Montgomery and decided that she
wanted to actually do something to
organize other women and she decided to
cook food she began to bake pies and
make chicken dinners and to sell these
as a way to raise money for the boycott
and she organized other domestic workers
to do the same thing and they ended up
throughout the course of the year
raising an enormous amount of money to
support the boycott and then we see a
number of local domestic worker groups
emerging around the country in Cleveland
Ohio in Detroit in Atlanta in New York
these various local groups come together
in 1971 and form a national organization
and they have a membership of 25,000
which is you know a pretty large number
SDS at its peak I think was around
30,000 so it's a very large number of
women around the country who have come
together and their biggest victory was
the passage of the Fair Labor Standards
Act in 1974 but put that in context
Pamela so 25,000 domestic workers are
now organized out of a total you'd
estimate of how many domestic workers in
the country as a whole maybe a million
and a half so it's a very small minority
of women who are organized but I'll just
say that I think social change always
happens with a very small minority of
people it's always a very small number
that are at the forefront of any
movement if you look at the civil rights
movement the vast majority of people in
the country were not engaged in the
civil rights movement so I think that's
how social change happens that's the
model I think of with this case as well
I probably agree with you but I would
like to push you just a little bit
further and ask you know normally when
we're when we function as historians we
try to think in terms of what kinds of
generalizations we can make from the
individual stories or those small bits
of data we gather do you have any
generalizations that you can make from
the 25,000 workers or the dozen or so
who really feature in your book it's
hard to make generalizations and and I
don't know that I want to make
generalizations about the mass of
african-american domestic workers at the
time I think I can talk about the women
who were organized and the women who
were a part of this movement and I think
they might reflect something broader in
the occupation
I think perhaps most important and one
of the reasons that this movement
resonated with women even who weren't
organized was a racial politics of the
occupation at that time for much of the
20th century African American women
had been the primary domestic labor
force and it was really a culture of
servitude that shaped that occupation
african-american women were often deemed
the mammy a an older woman who loyally
served a white family and really had no
needs or family of her own to take care
of it was a stereotype that was
popularized in in films and books in the
early part of the 20th century most
notably Gone with the Wind and that
stereotype I think in many ways framed
the occupation when women began to
organize in the 1960s I think part of
what they were hoping to do was to
transform the racial politics of the
occupation and I think they did so
fairly successfully we haven't talked
about race at all and we should and we
should also talk about immigration and
the way in which that effects the
politics of organizing domestic workers
can you say anything about that yeah the
women who organized in the 1960s were
actually organizing at a moment when the
occupation was transforming so the
removal of Jim Crow legislation meant
that African American women now had
other kinds of job opportunities open to
them so the vast majority of African
domestic workers were leaving the
occupation they were not staying as
domestic workers whereas these women who
I feature actually loved their work and
they want and they didn't want to leave
the occupation they wanted to remain
domestic workers but they just wanted to
be valued and respected for the work
that they did but as the mass of African
American women left the occupation large
numbers of immigrant were of immigrant
women were coming into the occupation
and immigrant women from all over the
country what I found most interesting in
my research was how the african-american
organizers didn't you know succumb to
xenophobia or hostility towards
immigrant workers but in fact their
approach was how do we bring these women
into our movement how can we work with
them how can we organize along
side them and so they tried very hard to
find ways to reach out the immigrant
women who are coming in and working as
domestic workers as well they weren't
always as successful at it
but I think their intention to do so is
actually admirable but now with my labor
history hat on it sounds as though what
you're saying is that supply and demand
influenced how domestic workers could
organize that is at the moment when they
were very much more in demand because
middle-class women were going out into
the labor force and when the numbers of
native-born black and white but mostly
black domestic workers was declining it
was then possible to make a push for
immigrant workers that wouldn't have
been possible in the 1940s or the 1930s
for example I think supply and demand
had a lot to do with it and I think that
that also shaped wide many middle-class
women were willing to support the
domestic worker organizing because I
think they saw it in their interests as
well to have an adequate supply of
domestic workers who were well paid
workers with with benefits but yes
definitely supply and demand played a
role in why I think some of this
organizing took place I think the
context of the civil rights movement was
also important and I think that the
social movements generally really gave
impetus to women who had been engaged in
civil rights organizing I want to agree
with you there but I also want to ask
you to talk about the feminist movement
because there I think is another place
where women middle-class women poor
women women could come together around
this issue that their interests were
really the same might cost them a little
more but happy people taking care of
children no matter who they were was
much better than unhappy people taking
care of children absolutely so there was
a very material interest
in why middle-class feminists might want
to support domestic worker organizing so
they have good people taking care of
their children but there was also an
intellectual connection as well many
middle-class feminists had done domestic
work in their own homes and had not been
paid for it and so I think there was a
recognition on their part about the
devaluation of housework whether it was
from their perspective or from the
perspective of paid domestic labor and
that was really the connection that was
made between middle-class feminists and
and the domestic workers who were
organizing I find this completely
fascinating because of course one of the
ways we started out the women's movement
in the early part of the 1970s was by
asking for pay for housework and we
still want pay for housework no matter
who does that
housework we want good pay for housework
absolutely and I think the big lesson we
can take away from this is the
importance and the value of the work
that takes place in the home and the
ways in which anybody who does it needs
to be respected for that work so let me
ask you a last question before we talk
to some actual domestic worker
organizers talk to us just a little bit
about how the organization of domestic
workers will enhance the lives of all
women I guess is the way I want to put
it in this moment of really fierce
transition in gender roles you mean in
that 60s and the 70s no no I mean now I
mean now this moment when so many women
are involved in to income families or in
supporting children and elderly parents
and so on on their own do you think
domestic worker organizing will enhance
and encourage a kind of stability and
sharing of the people who do domestic
work I think we have no alternative as a
number of scholars have talked about we
have in this country a crisis of social
reproduction we have a crisis in who's
taking care of the sick and the elderly
and the children and those who are
unable to take care of themselves we
have a crisis about how how things are
taken care of in the home when you have
two parents who are both employed
sometimes it's more than one job we need
people to do the care work and the
cleaning work in our everyday lives so I
think domestic work is more important
now than it has ever been in the past
and I think it is absolutely imperative
that we have a movement of women and men
who are organizing around this issue and
raising awareness about its value and as
well about the lives of domestic workers
themselves and what their needs are in
terms of their own care and their own
families I completely agree with you and
I hope everybody will read the book and
will recognize when they read the book
that this is the beginning of a story
and not the end of one by any means well
that is actually a great segue to our
representatives from the National
Domestic Workers Alliance Namrata who is
actually going to talk a little bit
about some of the campaigns and the
organizing that's going on right now
really
namaste good evening everyone my name is
Namrata Pradhan and I have been a nanny
since 2002 I'm a domestic worker
organizer and passionate about my work
as a nanny and I love my job and I'm
helping and raising two kids a three
year and a two year old I'm a second
mother teacher nurse friend and much
more I'm part of a parenting team with
my employers apart from being an
domestic worker I'm a community
organizer with a Dakar a human rights
and social justice organization working
with Nepali speaking community since
2005 Nepali spoken specially in Tibet
Bhutan and Burma and of course in Nepal
this year we organized to get temporary
protective status granted to Nepal after
the heavy earthquake and we also got the
healthy nail salons will pass in New
York State a Dakar is also an affiliate
and board member of the National
Domestic Workers Alliance and fought
alongside other grassroots organizations
to win the domestic workers Bill of
Rights in New York State in 2010 this
victory has inspired a national movement
to win inclusion for domestic workers in
basic labor protections but we know
while some key laws are in place such as
overtime pay and protection from
harassment there's still so much to work
to be done
the mr. workers need a living wage and
job security
Thomas workers constantly work in fear
of being fired anytime and when they
calculate the hours they work against
the weekly pay they often are below a
living wage but
domestic workers labor makes almost all
other labor in New York City possible
there are a resource to this global city
and they deserved to be treated with
dignity and respect this is the reason I
have decided to not only organize Nepal
speak into miracles but Caribbean
Latinos Filipinos all other domestic
workers from many corners of this world
today ndw a everydays across New York
have continued to fight for domestic
workers rights and dignity we have been
working with much more exported in the
industry living domestic workers
trafficking survivors women deliveries
we have in educating workers about their
rights coaching them negotiate better
standards and coordinating legal and
social services we have we have branded
with kernel worker Institute and Jewish
for racial and economic justice to offer
workforce training for nannies and elder
caregivers I have the opportunity to be
a proud graduate of the nanny training
in this moment we are fighting to win
domestic workers inclusion in the New
York City human rights law and we are
help developing a community led model
for implementing and enforcing domestic
workers right this commission is a big
issue we are trying to address in our
current colonising this commission of
all kind led to domestic workers
accepting lower standards which leads to
exploitation and wage theft and also
bust them unfairly from rock
opportunities to learn more about our
work please please find us in the back
at the side of her event and on behalf
of n.g.w i want to share how excited we
are to sponsor this book event for
household workers in unite professor
Madison has
and important early history of the
domestic worker movement that shares all
the important strategies and techniques
that me and other organizers can learn
from and be inspired by all the time
thank you very much I think you should
come and sit here because you'll be
asked questions and I don't think I will
be at this point
go ahead and open it up for any
questions any questions from the room
Premal walk I was interested in the fact
that all the geographical places you
mentioned are east of the Mississippi
and I wondered whether there is an
additional story or a different story
that takes place west of the Mississippi
that's an excellent question my stories
that I ended up focusing on were east of
the Mississippi because those were the
narratives that I found there were in
fact the number of domestic worker
organizations on the west coast but they
do have slightly different stories so
there were more Chicano organizations
especially in the later period on the
west coast there was one in Topeka
Kansas there was one in Seattle
Washington great congratulations for
such a wonderful book actually when
Alice was saying that or you were saying
that there is not that many studies of
domestic service well there are hundreds
of stories of domestic service but there
are very few studies of domestic
servants that is a big difference and
that what you have accomplished it and
not only few studies of domestic
servants there is even fewer students of
domestic servants trying to organize so
you is a double accomplishment so
congratulations related to to the
question of herb Scott a question which
I think has gotten any component as you
mentioned right that you were stood in a
period in which the number of African
Americans in the domestic service was
declining I would say that the domestic
service itself was declining 50 67 is
and then when it revived it was mostly
through immigrants right Latinos in the
West Coast but West Indians first in New
York and places like that
a now and that that's related also to
the question that I have which is there
are very few examples of labor
organizations of domestic servants right
historically and the few that there are
function more as mutually societies and
they have an ethnic component Swedish
servants in Chicago or something like
that so I want I was wondering if what
made this possible was not that these
people were domestic servants per se but
that they were African Americans and
outside of the South probably migrants
in South write migrants from the South
absolutely nearly all of the women I
write about actually were initially
involved in the civil rights movement
they were deeply involved in the civil
rights movement Dorothy Bolden in
Atlanta had worked closely with Martin
Luther King had worked to desegregate
the public school system in Atlanta and
actually it was a conversation with King
that she had where she talked to King
about the plight of domestic workers and
she told King somebody needs to organize
these workers and King told her well you
need to do it and so that's why she
decided to start this organization in
Atlanta so I think the question of being
african-american was absolutely central
to what the racial politics of the
occupation was at the center of the
movement their involvement in the civil
rights movement was a basis for how and
why they began to organize so I think
absolutely you know and in terms of your
other point about how the occupation was
declining it's absolutely true and
that's the backdrop for how and why I
think they were able to be successful
because the number of women who were
leaving the occupation was increasing
over the course of the 1960s and the
1970s in fact there were many
predictions in the early 70s that this
this occupation would would disappear
that in fact domestic workers would be
replaced by appliances and daycare
centers and things like that
but we know for a fact that that proved
not to be true perhaps because of
changes in the workforce and that middle
class
women were working at a higher rate and
the number of immigrant workers who were
coming in and then provided the supply
of labor I also want to congratulate you
on this wonderful book can't wait to
read it and I was really moved just to
think about how your scholarship is
directly in the service of an ongoing
social transformation project which is
just elevates its importance in so many
ways and this question I have is either
for either of you actually and just
thinking about the current period and
the internationalization of the domestic
worker population in New York I was
wondering if there was a kind of a
feedback or transfer where domestic
workers organized in New York traveling
to their different parts of the world or
their home countries whether we are
seeing like the emergence of domestic
worker organizing in other places as
well whether it was kind of diffusing
I'm only asking because I also know a
lot of domestic workers most of whom are
Nigerian right and so I don't see that
kind of diffusion right of a kind of
organizing politics moving to Nigeria
but I'm wondering if it's happening in
other parts of the world and if you
could speak to that thank you very much
we have been recently participating the
I did international domestic workers
forum there was a federation sorry
federation and you have been organizing
in South Asia I mean Hong Kong
especially and then there we have this
we want to know that we are all in the
same page we are just trying to get our
dignity and the respect and you know
when you ask for the right you have to
fulfill your duties too so we want to
know that it goes on from not only from
the
this this place this country where
everyone has the scenario of the land of
opportunity I myself is a human rights
lawyer in my country but I came as a I'm
a first immigrant coming with a big
dream to study here and ended up being a
domestic worker but I'm proud I want to
know that we are not only raising the
kids we are giving them we are raising
the citizen of any families were giving
a very good education to them so we want
to spread the news of message and to all
our sisters in all parts of the world
and I think Irene she's a New York
organizer from ndw so maybe she can
highlight some more about um so as
anumana pointed out we work with the
international domestic workers
Federation we help form the Federation
and we also help fight for an ILO
convention that was also passed in 2011
so it's international it sets
recommendations for standards I there
seeking for countries to ratify but
actually beyond just talking about what
we're doing there's a lot of exchange
around creative strategies about how we
organize domestic workers how it might I
into workforce development so sometimes
we're looking at a nanny training in
Bangladesh and we're comparing it to
what we're doing here and it's been
really exciting we actually you know
because we have figured out how to kind
of move resources to domestic worker
organizing we were able to have domestic
workers travel across the country travel
around the world it's people to talk to
each other about how they're leading how
they're organizing we just had two
domestic workers go to Bangkok and they
are part of these international
convenings
and also one was featured in a film that
was premiered there and so they got to
exchange with other domestic worker
leaders about how do we really implement
policy changes be able to do things on
the ground but also think about global
culture change and so Namrata has been a
part of that she's also travel for us
and been able to do that stride izing on
the ground in the US and around the
world
hi my question is for both of you that
organized and this may not be the most
politically correct question but I used
to work in Thailand with sex trafficking
organizations that work to rehabilitate
and help women in the sex trafficking
industry and I think a common Western
misconception is that if a woman is
trafficked she needs to get out and
oftentimes she would actually want to
continue the work she was doing but
didn't have any protections and because
this is an illegal industry there's not
much conversation around it but I know
that there's some overlap between
domestic work and sex trafficking
unfortunately so I was wondering how
that enters into your sphere and what
protections if any you're able to offer
or help in this country
yeah the dot about the trafficking as a
human trafficking is a big issue and our
one of our allies and we also do the her
diplomatic people I mean they're like
highly diplomat because they just bring
people from when they come to this
country to help for them so we and at
the car and the Mayan a Filipina
organization and even the help of ngw we
are fighting we have them to get rid of
the victim and to get the U visa for
them and it's like it's like a tradition
for them to they are not there beyond
the law because there are diplomatic so
they can't be in there in our laws so we
have been it's a full page to go there
but it's a starting point we haven't we
have been winning many cases about it so
and then it's a you it's a comedy work
is not so easy but with the full force
of everyone especially with the book
Pramila has been written is has inspired
and
it still now being 21st century but
still is going on but will be and one
day we have the hope I really appreciate
your question actually came a similar
route so I used to work with young women
in Miami who were considered being
commercially sexually compulsive
exploitation and we're seen as victims
and also as survivors and that actually
eventually led me to Thailand where I
worked at the LOI ILO and I was thinking
I was going to work on trafficking
issues with sex workers and I was making
a lot of differentiations between how
the work is viewed and labeled and
actually end up falling also into
understanding and you know having the
opportunity to understand domestic work
so I think about those two things in
parallel
often nimrod says work runs deep with
the trafficking survivors community here
in new york and definitely i think the
cases that come up
they are truly trafficking like it's
trafficking it's worse like the
underbelly of New York New York City
even New York State we see some really
terrible things happen or even just I
mean even if it's not abuse on a
day-to-day basis it's you know being
unable to leave your home having your
family at home being threatened so I
think you know there's some similarities
but there's also for us a distinction
and we're also very clear at least in
the domestic worker trafficking issues
that we work on we very much use a model
of organizing so how do we make sure
that survivors are leaders at the center
of our strategy in that communities
actually respond as a whole to domestic
worker trafficking and I see that a lot
of that emerges too with sex workers and
also cases where there is trafficking
but what Adi car and Dom ion and UWA I
think has really discovered is something
really different and something really
brilliant about how we look at this
issue but again be able to develop
leaders who are really organizing and
using that model to create policy change
not just to shift the fate of one
individual but thinking
is a huge community responsibility any
other questions
okay I thank you everybody for coming
thank you again to prevail in Dallas and
Namrata and we'll have plenty of copies
available if you'd like to have a copy
signed and thank you again for coming to
book culture
[Applause]
you're watching book TV television for
serious readers watch any program you
see here online at book TV org
and we wrap up our visit to Oakland
California with Cara Butler author of
raised what 4-h teaches 7 million kids
and how its lessons could change food
and farming forever 4-h is an
organization that focuses on youth
development and it serves 7 million kids
in the United States and around the
world
4-h began in at the turn of the last
century in 1902 1903 and it was actually
a project of the agricultural extensions
that the universities there were
professors there who were figuring out
new ways of farming tractors and all
kinds of newfangled breeding seed
breeding techniques and the problem that
they were running up against was that
the farmers were a little bit wary of
these these new newfangled ways of
farming these were people who had been
doing things the same way since they
their ancestors came over from Europe so
very cleverly some of the people at the
Agricultural Extension decided to start
a club for kids of the farmers and they
they started with corn growing contests
and they they gave the kids hybrid seeds
and they said to the kids you know why
don't you grow your own plots and we'll
see how it goes
and when they're parents how well the
new plots grew using these hybrid seeds
and some new techniques and some new
technology as well they were interested
in those techniques and the seeds as
well so it really started out as a way
for the universities to reach out to the
nation's farmers the kids that I
followed were all from the Bay Area and
they're all teenagers and this is a
little bit unusual for 4-h in that most
of the kids who live in urban and
suburban areas are not involved in
livestock projects and these kids that I
was following were they were raising
goats and sheep
pigs and rabbits well these kids who are
raising livestock are working toward one
main goal which is the County Fair
and so the Fair is you know there there
are competitions sort of smaller
competitions throughout the year but the
Fair is kind of the culmination of the
4-h year for kids who are raising
livestock there are kind of two ways
that you can compete in the fair the
first way is through the sheep or the
animal itself and how well it conforms
to the standards of the breed so
basically how how beautiful and how you
know how strong and how graceful your
your animal is and you can control this
with how you feed the sheep how you take
care of the Sheep how you groom the
sheep even but then the other
competition which I thought was actually
much more interesting was called
showmanship and this is where you as the
presenter you as the 4-h err show how
well you've trained your sheep and show
this kind of rapport that you've
developed with your sheep so this is
where you would take the the Sheep
around in the ring and you know you
would show the judges that it responds
to your commands and that you've you
know groomed it in a certain way and
that you really know how to handle the
Sheep it's whereas you know that the
first kind is a competition that's about
the animal the second kind is really
about the kit I guess maybe the thing
that really surprised me was the extent
to which these kids are consumed by 4h
the the amount of time that they
dedicate to raising these animals I sort
of you know I was a Girl Scout when I
was a kid and I sort of like went to
meetings when I remembered too you know
it was like a fun thing but it wasn't
anything too major these kids spend
hours and hours every day bonding with
their animals training their animals
grooming their animals feeding their
animals calculating the exact ratio of
protein that that the feed needs to have
in order for the animals to grow at a
certain rate and it's not even just the
kids it's also the club leaders
and the kids families that the amount of
time and energy and dedication that goes
into raising these animals was really
quite remarkable
these are market class animals which
means that at the end of the fair if
you're raising sheep or pigs or cows or
meat goats then there will be an auction
and as a forager it's your
responsibility to find somebody who is
likely to buy your animal for meat at
the end of the fair an auction is very
it's a very kind of emotional event you
see people crying saying goodbye to
their animals but you know when you talk
to these kids most of them get so much
out of the relationship that they've
developed with the animal and they
really get a lot out of learning exactly
where their meat comes from that you
know even if it's a sad occasion the
auction it's kind of bittersweet because
they really have learned to appreciate
this like this lifecycle it really 4-h
clubs reflect the communities that
they're in so if you have a diverse
community then you're probably going to
have a diverse 4-h club that said
raising livestock presents a problem
because it's a it's expensive so there
is not a lot of socio-economic diversity
and the among the kids who raise
livestock you have to be able to pay for
feed you have to be able to buy the
animal itself by all these grooming
supplies and there are some clubs that
are offering scholarships and you know
searching out grants there's a really
cool model in Austin Texas where schools
that serve populations that normally
wouldn't be able to afford to do this
have gotten a bunch of grants and are
making this kind of activity raising
goats available to all the public school
kids at a few schools but in other
places you see you know kids whose
parents have the means
can raise livestock and kids whose
parents don't can't the kids that I
followed Kelly the girl who was raising
sheep in Castro Valley she is 100%
positive that she is going to become a
large-animal vet she is dedicated to it
this is going to be her life and
actually this is sort of a PostScript to
the book that I've never written but I
should she ended up she graduated from
high school and she ended up going to UC
Davis which has an awesome veterinary
science program and she in her sophomore
year of college ended up being the
campus shepherdess so she was living in
a barn with sheep her dorm room was in
the Sheep barn so she was earning a
little extra money and having her her
housing her you know college housing and
I think room and board paid for and
meanwhile here it was I visited her last
year and here it was and in the middle
of lambing season and she was on call 24
hours a day to help the they use give
birth to the new Lambs so this was like
her college job you know and so she I
mean this was really a passion of hers
that that is going to become her career
as for the other kids that I followed
I'm not so sure that they're eventually
gonna end up being farmers or anything
4-h was more like a very meaningful
extracurricular for them but if you went
to 4-h clubs in the heartland I think
you would find more kids like Kelly who
this is really what they want to do and
they're they're kind of sowing the seeds
of the rest of their lives as they're in
4h club
for more information on book TVs recent
visit to Oakland and the many other
destinations on our city's tour go to
c-span org slash cities tour
here's a look at some authors recently
featured on book TVs afterwards our
weekly interview program
Darcy Olson president of the Goldwater
Institute took a critical look at the
review period new medications must
undergo to receive FDA approval rural
Medical Association president Michael
Marmot reported on the factors
contributing to America's health and
wellness gap and nurse and to New York
Times columnist Teresa Brown spoke about
the challenges patients face in the
health care system in coming weeks on
afterwards Fox News correspondent James
Rosen looks at former vice president
Dick Cheney's time in the Bush
administration Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist Mei Fong talks about the
effects of China's one-child policy also
coming up former senators Tom Daschle
and Trent Lott offer their solutions to
resolve the current state of
partisanship in Washington and this
weekend Carl